ted williams wrote a book called the  science of hitting and ended he had a  picture of himself at bat and the strike  zone broken into i think 77 squares  and he said if he waited for the pitch  that was really in his sweet spot he  would bat 400 and if he had to swing at  something on the lower corner he would  probably bat 235  and in investing i'm in a no called  strike business which is the best  business you can be and  i can look at a thousand different  companies and i don't have to be right  on every one of them or even 50 of them  so i can pick the ball i want to hit  [Music]  and the trick in investing  is just to sit there and watch pitch  after pitch go by  and wait for the water right in your  sweet spot and if people are yelling  swing you bump ignore